ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนนะคะครูฟ้า
คะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพุธค่ะ
อันนี้กูจะเขียนช้านิดหน่อยนะคะนักเรียน
ขอโทษด้วยๆข้างผู้หญิงที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 1
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
a คศอะไรคะ
มีข้อสอ
2022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันวันที่ 31 เดือนอะไร
คะเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพศษส
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 2 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอน
นี้เวลา 15:00 น
3:00 นกี่นาที 5 อีก 2 นาที
3:52 นาทีนก็เป็นตอนกลางวันนี้นะคะ
เปลี่ยนก่อนทรายบ่ายแล้ว
อ่ะวันนี้ครูหญิงไว้เท้าแล้วคุณจะอยู่
บ้างกูฟ้าอยู่บ้านใช่ไหมคะ
ครูฟ้าอยู่อเมริกาผู้หญิงแต่ว่าอยู่บ้าน
ที่อเมริกาอยู่บ้านที่อเมริกาน่ะกล้วยครู
ฟ้าอยู่บ้านที่อเมริกางั้นก็ดีค่ะครูหญิง
มีคำถามสถานภูฟ้าเลยผู้หญิงจะถามครูฟ้า
ว่าอะไรนิดอะไรให้มึงกิน
ครูหญิงด้วยถามครูปลาว่าที่บ้านครูฟ้าที่
อเมริกาเนี่ยมีอันนี้ไหม
มีอะไร
แนะนำแถมอะไรคะ
กระดาษ of
เบคอนเบคอนที่บ้านกรูปาที่อเมริกามีเบคอน
ไหม
ช่วยต้องไทยค่ะภาษาไทยได้ไหมคะ
มีสิหามีเบคอนเพราะว่ากูฟ้าเนี่ยกูปลา
ทำไม
ชอบนะคะเบคอนของ Fast อยากจะแต่งงานกับ
เบคอนเหรอ
ครูบาชอบกินเบคอนค่ะครูหญิง
ครูฟ้าชอบกินเมคอนงั้นคุณฟ้าก็ต้องรู้จัก
เบคอนแน่นอน
ครูฟ้าใช่ผู้หญิงนะคะว่ารู้ฟ้ารู้ไหมคะ
ว่าเบคอนเนี่ยทำมาจากมีอะไรหรือว่าเบคอน
ทําจากอะไร
ไหม
รู้
เบคอนทําจากอะไรคะ
เบคอนก็ทำจาก
วงกลม
จุด
คิดชุดเดียวผู้หญิง 2 จุดสุดหายหรือยังไง
นักเรียนรู้ไหมอะไร
วาดอะไรแล้วนักเรียนรู้ไหม Day ค่อนทำมา
จากอะไร
อะไรก็ครูฟ้า
หมูค่ะผู้หญิงขอครูฟ้าบอกว่าเบคอนทำมาจาก
หมู
ใช้ใช่ไหมจริงหรอไม่รู้ดูรูปต่อไป
ได้เหล็กเตือนฉันแถมแถมแถมแถมฉันแจ่มเย้
เพลง
ชนิดนี้คือเนื้อหมู
คือแนวหมูและ
เนื้อหมูใช่ค่ะเบคอนทำจากเนื้อหมูเย้นิ
นั้นนะคะอร่อยเก่งมากค่ะวิ่งนี้อีกค่ะครู
ฟ้าครูฟ้ารู้ไหมคะว่าอันนี้คืออะไร
รู้ค่ะอะไรคะช็อกโกแลต
ภาษาไทยช็อกโกแลตจะใช้กับช็อกโกแลต
Chocolate ช็อกโกแลตอะไรก็ได้เรียน
ครูอาร์ทชอบกินช็อกโกแลตไหม
ชอบมากๆครูฟ้าชอบกินช็อกโกแลตแล้วครูฟ้า
รู้ไหมคะว่าช็อกโกแลต The  Bat ทำมาจาก
อะไร
รู้ค่ะนี่ช็อกโกแลตทำมาจากอะไรคะ
ช็อกโกแลตทำมาจาก
อะไรคะเป็นสีเขียว
ต้น
เหมือนต้นอยู่บ้านอะไรเขาเข้า
ภาษาไทยคะโกโก้
คนโก้มาดูว่าไทยหรือเปล่าช็อกโกแลตทำมา
จากโกโก้หรอทุกแล้วก็ทำมาจากช็อกโกแลต
กับช็อกโกแลตเนี่ยมีแรง
Google มะละกอน่ะใช่ค่ะนี่ไงนี่ไงอยู่
วันนี้กูพาว่าใช่ไหมลูกแล้วถ่านมันจะเป็น
ยาวให้พ่อแกะออกมาข้างในก็จะมีเม็ดเนี่ย
เม็ดอันนี้นะเม็ด Google ใช่ไหมคะที่เป็น
Google เดี๋ยวเราเลี้ยงปลอบเขาบอกว่าทำ
มาจากเม็ด go  go  go ฟ้าโกโก้
s  m  m  let  go  go  go  med โกโก้ก็
เอาไปทำเป็นชักโกแลต Chocolate
มาหา 2 แบบ
โอเคเดี๋ยวขอเคยนักเรียนมีอีกค่ะ
her  Profile รู้ไหมคะอันนี้อะไร
ลูกเกดลูกเกดครูฟ้าชอบกินลูกเกดไหม
ครูฟ้า
อยู่หน้าเข้าใจเลย
โผใหญ่ไปไหมคะ
ชอบกินลูกเกด
ดีมากค่ะครูหญิงไปบ้านครูฟ้าครูหญิงซื้อ
ลูกเกดมาผู้หญิงกิน
อยู่คนเดียวเย้
มายความไม่ชอบกินลูกเกดหครูหญิงนักเรียน
คะนักเรียนเนี่ยคิดว่านักเรียนดูวีดีโอ
เราฟังครูหญิงกับครูฟ้ามานานครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ชอบกินทุกอย่างตอนนี้วีดีโอนี้นักเรียน
รู้แล้วครูบาวไม่ชอบลูกเกรซไม่ชอบลูกเกด
อ้าวครูมาไม่ชอบลูกเกดแต่ครูฟ้ารู้ไหมว่า
ลูกเกดทําจากอะไรหรือทำมาจากอะไร
หนูค่ะ
ทำมาจากอะไรคะลูกเกดลูกเกดทํามาจากเงิน
เงิน
องุ่นไม่หุ่นเป็นยังไงวาดรูปได้ไหมองุ่น
เป็นอย่างนี้
เต็มที่ไปวัดนึง
หนูมานี่เลย
หงุดหงิดเบอร์รี่คะขอคุยอะไร
วัดองุ่นวัน
นี้ก็ว่าแล้วมั้ยนี่ไงมึงก็ว่าแค่นี้
เนี้ยมาต้านอนุมูลแล้วเนี่ยอรุณ
กูว่าพญามา
ดีมากค่ะซ่อนสวยนะฮะอ่ะครูฟ้าบอกว่า
อะไรเนี่ยรูปลูกเกดนะคะทำมาจากนั่งอุ่น
แสงองุ่นก็คือแล้วก็เป็นลูกเกดนะคะขอดู
ว่าครูฟ้าจะถูกไหมก็กูป่าวไม่ชอบกิน
ลูกเกดพี่บี
เฮเสียงหุ่น
องุ่น
แล้วก็มีดวงไม่ใช่ไหม
เอาองุ่นเนี่ยไปตากแดดแล้วองุ่นก็จะพอดวง
อาทิตย์เนี่ยมันร้อนเนาะร้อน 40 องศา
เซลเซียสหุ่นก็แห้งแล้วก็เป็นลูกเกดนะคะ
จิโร่แคคู่ฟ้าเนี่ยชอบกินองุ่นนะคะแต่ไม่
ชอบลูกเกดๆไม่ชอบลูกเกด
ได้ค่ะผู้หญิงให้องุ่นครูฟ้าและผู้หญิงก็
กินลูกเกดได้ไงผู้หญิงขอบคุณมากค่ะไม่ชอบ
กินองุ่นเหรอคะโอเคค่ะผู้หญิงไม่ใช่ชอบ
ไม่ชอบถ้ามีเอลูกเกด bl อุ่นผู้หญิงกิน
ลูกเกดไม่กินองุ่นร้องหรอโอ้นี่เลยกูไป
ชอบกินองุ่นมากนะค่ะดีกับเราจะได้ไม่ต้อง
ทะเลาะกันมีอีกนะภูฟ้า
รู้กูมารู้ไปหานี่อะไรอ่ะเลือกครีม
โยเกิร์ตหิวเปเรซ
เหนื่อยภาษาไทยได้ไหมเลย
เนยฮะเนยอันนี้นะคะ
Cheese  it ค่ะ
อะไรคะเนยแข็งเอ้า
เหมือนกันอันนี้เนยเนยแข็งนะคะหรือว่าเลย
แข็ง aka  Cheese
ครูป๊า
โยเกิร์ตเนยแล้วก็เลยแข็งหรือชีสเนี่ยนะ
คะทำมาจากอะไรทำมาจากนี้หากผู้หญิงไหมคะ
อะไรอ่ะกูอะไร
มีเขาพูดว่าเพราะว่าเขานะคะอ่ะ
เนื้อ
หา
อะไรคะครูป่าวยืน point เท้าด้วยนะคะ
กุกาว่าตัวอะไร
ฟ้าวาดห้องนะเขาวาดก่อนนะค่ะ
วัว
ใส่ให้ค่ะผู้หญิงพาวาสวัวทำเนยชีสเนยแล้ว
ก็โยเกิร์ตทำมาจากบัวเหรอคะ
นมนี่ไง
ไหนต้องมีฐาน
ตัวอยู่บนอะไร
ผู้หญิงนมวัวนมวัวไม่รู้ว่าใช่ไหมค่ะ
ช่อเย้ไอ้น้องไม่ไหวนมแล้วก็นมวัว
ๆหนูกลัวไม่ใช่วัวนะคะทำชีสทำเนยทำเนย
แล้วก็ทำโยเกิร์ตได้ไหมอาจจะเป็นนมนมแพ้
นายนมแพะ
แบะนมแพะ
ดูละสิเนี่ยอ้ารู้อะไรมาหาไอ้เก่งมากค่ะ
ครูป๊าใยอาหารแล้วว่าต่อไปหนูปารู้คือ
อะไร
อะไรคะครูฝาที่กูป้าเห็นอยู่เนี่ย
กระเป๋าแล้วครับเอ๋าอะไรกระเป๋าหนัง
กระเป๋าหนังกระเป๋าหนังก็ต้องทำมาจากหนัง
ใช่ไหมอันนี้คือหนังอาร์ขอราคาไงค่ะนะคะ
ก็หนังอันนี้มีเข็มใช่ไหมแล้วก็เย็บๆ
นาเย็บแล้วก็ก็เป็นกระเป๋าน้องเราก็เลย
เรียกว่ากระเป๋าหนังแล้วครูฟ้ารู้ไหมว่า
กระเป๋าหนังเนี่ยหนังที่เอามาทำกระเป๋าคำ
มาจากหนังอะไร
หนังที่เอามาทำกระเป๋าจระเข้
จระเข้
หูฝาปกติตัวละเข้เขาไม่เอามาทำกับเขาเอา
มาทำนั่นแหละแต่ว่ามันแพงไงหนังจระเข้อัน
นี้คือจระเข้นะคะนักเรียน
ไม่ต้องให้หนังจระเข้
แล้วหนังอะไรอ่ะ
ถ้าอย่างนี้ว่าจริงหรอจริงเปล่าไม่เคยได้
ยินหรอกระเป๋าหนังวัวหนังกลัวเนี่ยมันจะ
นิ่มๆนิ่มๆหนังวัวเพราะเรากลัวอยู่แล้วไง
กินกลัวแต่เราไม่กินไหนใช่มั้ยก็ทำมาจาก
หนังวัววัว
หนังวัวหนังแกะนะค่ะเนี่ยเนี่ยซ้ายจะไม่
ใช่อันนี้นะนี่คือขนนะขนไม่ใช่คนนะคะนัก
เรียนต้องโกนโกนโกนขนออกก่อนก็จะมีหนัก
เนาะหนังแกะแล้วก็หนังแพะ
ส่วนใหญ่นะอ่าหนังสัตว์อะไรก็ได้เนาะเอา
มาทำกระเป๋าหนัง
ก็ไม่ใช่ของกินไม่รู้เลยนะคะนักเรียนมี
อีกค่ะครูฟ้า
อะไรคะครูหญิงลูกค้าเห็นอะไรคะนี้เครื่อง
น้ำมันดินเผาแอร์แอร์เครื่องปั้นดินเผา
ใช่ไหมคะอาจจะเป็นแจกันนอนนี้ก็เป็นใจกัน
มีดอกไม้นานามีดอกไม้ใช่ไหมแจกันแล้วก็มี
ดอกไม้
ซึ่งแต่ว่าอันนี้ก็จะเป็นอะไรเนี่ยอันนี้
ทิ้งขยะน้านิสัยอาหารมาใส่อาหารได้ไฟฟ้า
รู้ไหมคะว่าเครื่องปั้นดินเผาเนี่ยทำมา
จากอะไร
รู้ค่ะชุดนานจัง
รู้ค่ะหรือทำจากอะไรคะทำมาจากอะไรคะ
ทำมาจาก
ดินนะ
ตายดินอะไหล่
ดินเหนียว
สวยเพราะว่า
ผู้หญิงเรียนนิดนึงอ้ะพูดดินใช่ไหมมันจะ
มีดินชี้เป็น
ดินทรายหนอนดินทรายดินทรายเนี่ยทะเลหาว่า
นักเรียนไปทะเลกำลังจะไปทะเลเนี่ยก็จะมี
ดีนะนิเราเรียกว่าดินทรายนะคะเงียบแต่ไม่
ใช่นะไม่ใช่ดินทราย
แล้วก็จะมีดิน
ที่เวลานักเรียนเนี่ยปลูกต้นไม้มนุษย์
หมายเนี่ยก็จะมีดินทำไมที่รากดินที่ปลูก
ต้นไม้หรือไม่ใช่ร่างนะคะขอโทษพูดอ้ะดิน
เนาะ
ดินที่ปลูกต้นไม้เนี่ยเราเรียกดินร่วน
หน่วยดินร่วนเนี่ยก็ไม่ใช่นะคะครูฟ้าบอก
ว่าทำมาจากดินเหนียว
ดินเหนียวไปดูสิว่าไหวๆๆ
จะมี
ถูกฆ่าตายเอ้อ
เกมเอ-คอนแล้วไม่ต้องดีใจมากมาหานี้นะคะ
เป็นดินมาค่ะดิน
ดินดินเหนียวใช่ไหมเอามาปั้นราคาปั้นครู
ฟ้าทำได้ไหมคะปั้น
ไม่เคยทำค่ะผู้หญิงก็ไม่เคยน่าจะยากแล้ว
เมื่อใช่วันที่ว่าทำได้นะอ๋อใช่ไหมเนี่ย
ดินเหนียวนะคะก็คือถ้าเป็นดินทรายหรือว่า
ดินร่วนที่ปลูกต้นไม้เนี่ยปั้นไม่ได้เนาะ
ต้องใช้ดินเหนียว
เออพี่หนึ่งครับรูปาอะไรคะเสื้อไหมพรม
ผู้หญิงกินแล้ว
เสียวไหมพรมไปใช่หรอเสื้อขนสาดเอ้า
หมุนขนใช่ไหมเราเดี๋ยวนี้อาจจะไม่ใช่คน
ของคนขนสัตว์อันนี้ประเทศไทยไม่มีไม่ต้อง
ใส่นะคะว่ามันหนาวประเทศไทยมันร้อนใส่ไม่
ได้อ่าเสื้อขนสัตว์
มันก็จะเป็นขนทรายขนขนๆฝนฝนขนของสัตว์ครู
ฟ้าคิดว่ามันก็ต้องทำมาจากขนใช่มั้ยเนี่ย
ฝน
อันนี้คือขนนะครับขนอันนี้เนาะแล้วก็เอา
มา
ผักวะเอามาถามเราว่าถามแล้วก็เปลี่ยนเป็น
เสื้อขนสัตว์สีฟ้าคิดว่าขนอะไร
คนรู้จักขนอะไร
คนหมี
พูดได้ไหมคะนักเรียนรองเท้าและ
ขนหมีไงนักเรียนเอ้อ
เหตุผลหมี
ผู้หญิงก็อ้าไม่ได้ว่าแล้วก็นี่อ้าวขนหมี
ไม่ใช่ว่าเห็นในวันสีขาวนี่หนาว
polar  Bear เหรอ
คนหมีขาวขนหมีขาวไม่ใช่ถ้า
ขนแพะอะไร
มีแม่แบบไม่รู้ไงนะ
โคนรุ่นแจ็สขนแกะ
ไปเธอ a  day มีอย่างหนึ่งขนอัลปาก้าขอ
ได้ใช่ไหมไม่รู้กี่ท่ออัลปาก้าใช่ๆแกะอ่ะ
ไงขนแกะสมัยเราเขาก็จะโกนโกนขนแกะแต่ก็
แบบนี้นะคะพอแกะตายหรือเปล่าก็ไม่รู้นะคะ
ก็จะเอาไปทำเป็นหลัง
มาแล้วกระเป๋า
ถ้าทำเป็นหนังต้องตายแล้วล่ะนายอะนั่น
แหละนะเรียนก็วันนี้มาเล่นเกมกับครูฟ้า
ใช่มั้ยถามว่าของแต่ละอย่างทำจากอะไรนะ
เห็นไหมนักเรียนถูกกล่าวก็คอมเม้นท์บอกก็
ได้นะคะแต่ว่าไอ้ตัวนี้กูเองกับภูฟ้าก็
ต้องไปแล้วเดี๋ยวเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะ
คะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะพูดมา